could be you we are selling tickets at
the merchandise table across the hall in
the Gordon Chapel which is also where
James will be signing books after the
session so while you're waiting in line
to get your book signed you can be
filling out your raffle ticket and
proceeds go to benefit the Boston Book
Festival thank you
and now let's not waste any more time
and get to the main event please join me
in welcoming James Glick and Tom
Ashbrook Thank You Debbie
thank you very much welcome James just
off the train from New York thank you
Tom I'm happy to be here wonderful to
have you first question can you get us
out of this time I mean I really need to
get out of this time you know I'm
hearing a lot Els ready to get out of
here oh my god future past I don't care
yeah I I heard somebody suggest that
wouldn't it be possible to travel back
in time and teach a certain future
dictator manners which I thought was a
good variation on the theme of going
back in time and killing Hitler at least
a more polite variation now here I said
thinking which future dictator yeah you
write about so much I mean you've
written about chaos and genius and
information about Isaac Newton and
Richard Fineman now you're writing about
time I really love this book this was
just awesome I wish you'd put us in a
time machine
right off the bat and take us back to
1895 would you just read from the very
beginning of your book a man stands at
the end of a drafty corridor aka the
19th century and in the flickering light
of an oil lamp examines a machine made
of nickel and ivory with brass rails and
quartz rods a squat ugly contraption
somehow out-of-focus not easy for the
poor reader to visualize despite the
listing of parts and materials our hero
fiddles with some screws
adds a drop of oil and plants himself in
the saddle he grasps a lever with both
hands he is going on a journey and by
the way so were we
when he throws that lever time breaks
from its moorings
the man is nondescript
almost devoid of features grey eyes and
a pale face and not much else he lacks
even a name he is just the time
traveller for so will be convenient to
speak of him time and travel no one had
thought to join those words before now
and that machine with its saddle and
bars it's a fantastic ated bicycle the
whole thing is the invention of a young
enthusiast named Wells who goes by his
initials HG because he thinks that
sounds more serious than Herbert his
family calls him Bertie
he's trying to be a writer he's a
thoroughly modern man a believer in
socialism free love and bicycles thank
you thank you James lick reading for the
beginning of time travel and very
quickly very quickly we're on to this
nowadays we voice two times so easily
and well and so in our dreams in our art
time travel feels like an ancient
tradition rooted in old mythologies
oldest gods and Dragons it isn't though
the ancients imagined immortality and
rebirth and lands of the dead time
machines will be on there Ken
time-travel is a fantasy of the modern
era when wells in his lamp lit room
imagined a time machine he also invented
a new mode of thought really real I
thought that I mean what about Scrooge
what about a Connecticut Yankee in King
Arthur's Court what about I don't know
didn't Thor or somebody in the
bhagavad-gita
move around through yeah yeah we didn't
think wouldn't you I mean that's that
was really this is really the starting
point for me thinking that there was a
history to be written if time travel it
was the idea that time travel actually
isn't that ancient because it's such an
obvious idea I mean it just seems like
time travel is no weirder
no more should be no more obscure than
breakfast you know it should have been
less no.22 well why shouldn't it have
always been there you know why should
old Eve's men have a massive difference
with Oh Verdie wells well yes Charles
Dickens had if you want to look for
counter examples yes Christmas past
Christmas future but nobody is actually
traveling through time he is as the 19th
century goes on and he wasn't long
before well he was starting to think
about well the past the future and of
course people had always thought about
the future in a certain way they would
consult fortune tellers and soothsayers
and you know read tea leaves literally
and when they were doing that they were
mostly thinking about their own future
isn't right will I meet a Tall Dark
Stranger sort of thing okay and you and
you also mentioned Connecticut Yankee in
King Arthur's Court which is a great
example and it's five years before
Welles and it is a kind of time travel I
mean you can make the case his hero our
hero the Connecticut Yankee I'm sure I'm
sure you all remember travel we have a
number in the audience right now of
Connecticut Yankees of Yankees anyway
well this Yankee Hank was a factory
engineer a real can-do guy he was he was
a geek he was up to date with all the
latest technology just as Mark Twain was
Mark Twain was the first guy on his
block to have a typewriter Anna Anna
telephone he loved all that stuff and
and it's not a rope trying to build
fancy technology for printing in those
days yeah and so what's the mechanism of
time travel
five years before HG Wells invents a
machine Hank gets whacked on the head in
a fight yes and then he wakes up and
he's in a field and there's a town in
the distance and there's a horse with a
you know fancy blanket and on the horse
there's a guy wearing armor and he says
Hartford and the knight says Camelot of
course and we're and we're off and the
the engine of Twain's story is kind of
part of the argument I'm trying to make
about wells
it's that suddenly people were aware of
the difference between the technology
that they had and the technology of the
past 20 they didn't have time traveling
technology but they had suddenly trains
and Telegraph's and exactly and they
were synchronizing clocks using their
Telegraph's and so they were thinking
about time and they were also thinking
for the first time what will the future
be like how will the future be different
for my children and grandchildren
what sort of wonders and marvels will
the year 2000 bring mm-hmm because they
were just it was just five years before
1900 in 1900 everybody was very excited
it was the turn of the century there
were celebrations looking back there
weren't a lot of celebrations it wasn't
a big deal when the 18th century ended
in the 19th century began but this time
it was because this forward thrust of
the technology people worth were
futurists they were thinking about the
future and that was HG Wells he was a he
was a future guy but was he science
oriented he wrote in here clearly the
time travel preceded any real body must
have extension in four directions it
must have length breadth thickness and
duration and you write ah the fourth
dimension was this birdie Wells being a
scientist Oh what's going on here right
so this is for people who don't know
this is the big this is the way the time
machine begins it begins with the time
traveler
giving a little lecture to his friends
to set up the story and he has to
justify this impossible idea that you
could have a machine that would travel
through time and so the way he does it
is to give a sort of I think to modern
ears that sounds fairly pompous and
pedantic a little lecture to his friends
like that and he tells them everything
that you learned about time is wrong
time is it's just another dimension like
space you can imagine it as a direction
and every object has four dimensions and
the fourth dimension is duration and if
it didn't have any duration it would
only exist for an instant and so we have
to imagine it extending into the past
and into the future
and so I've made a machine that can zoom
along on that track
I'm not impossible to imagine track but
there's something different about the
palpable the the visceral sort of
reality of this you right the remind us
that in Victorian England this time in
proceeding him then fourth dimension
idea was out there but you say was
served as a catch-all a hideaway for the
mysterious the unseen the spiritual
anything that seemed to be lurking just
out of sight heaven might be in the
fourth dimension Wells takes us where
Wells of course takes us into the future
he is thinking about time as the fourth
dimension and fourth dimension as a
thing in geometry is something
mathematicians have speculated about it
was obscure but it was in the air wells
wasn't inventing it magically and of
course it was ten years later that
Einstein published his first at that
point obscure paper in a physics journal
on special relativity in which he is
imagining time as exactly that a fourth
dimension and that's why when you know
for us we know time is the fourth
dimension right nobody was surprised by
that idea wells Wells as time traveler
had to explain it to his pals think
about it and they didn't believe it and
they had to argue about it if you know
if we're writing the story now we don't
have to bother with all that stuff
because we already know it you write in
short surprisingly short order this
notion we become part of
orthodoxy of theoretical physics he
wrote about time travel but you say not
as a scientist so much as a you wanted
to you want to sell books you want a
good story yeah that was his throughout
this book wonderful book there's a
tension between the sort of scientific
view of this and the poetic or the
literary view of time travel
take us through time travel except what
were the with their scientific
propositions that were put on the table
one after another about whether this
could happen and how it might happen
over the century sense I should say it's
not well as you know it's not really a
book about the science no it's not of
time-travel it's not you sort of just
sucked us in it's like the time-travel
is the flashy billboard out front it's
time if anybody is if anybody is
planning to buy the book hoping that
there will be you know an instruction
manual at the on yeah in the middle
there's a whole you're about to be
disappointed because there isn't that
much science of time-travel but there is
there is some there are people now there
are physicists now who love to talk
about time-travel wormholes right
interstellar I'm sure a lot of you saw
was had as a producer and scientific
adviser a very serious relativist kip
thorne of Caltech it's a sexy idea even
if it's I would say impossible but so my
story is really about how the idea
develops on parallel tracks and not just
the idea of time travel but a whole
assortment of a whole assortment of ways
of thinking about time that suddenly
became unsettled and thrown up for grabs
and so philosophers were worrying about
time as they always had but now they
were worrying in new ways because they
were reading Albert Einstein and he was
a schoolboy in Munich when HG Wells
brought this out in 1895 that's right
and so and so soon after philosophers
had to start to deal with ideas of
relativity and it was coming at them
from left field and there were
philosophers who also said well let's
examine this and I'm here let's look at
this fantasy by HG Wells and analyze
that philosophically
what did it disrupt in terms of standing
philosophy well philosophy before
Einstein took over had a view of time
William James thought a lot about time
Omri barracks and thought about time
these were people who were thinking
about the psychology of time and they
were interested in questions that
interest all of us still how do we
perceive time why is our perception of
time so malleable
you know why does why does a month seem
to stretch on into eternity when we're
six years old and it goes by in an eye
blink when were when were my age but
scientists were not interested so much
in the perception of time they needed
time to be a very real thing and
Einstein on the one hand was was
throwing open the doors and forcing us
to reevaluate the way we think about
time but on the other hand he was
following in the tradition of Newton and
everybody who had come since in in
making sure the time was mathematical it
was a very real thing it was to be
measured it wasn't just to be thought of
with the fuzzy language that that
philosophers like to use resist that a
lot in here I feel you coming down
heavily on the side of philosophers and
poets in the literary maybe not on the
side I I don't I I like the scientists
you know I've been writing about
physicist myelitis but they don't own
time any more than the philosophers do
any more than the psychologists do our
conception of time I've come to feel is
an assortment of things it's a
hodgepodge of things and it's influenced
by science fiction writers and it's
influenced by literary writers who also
were were doing something very new in
the same year that we're talking about
Marcel Proust was practically a
contemporary of Welles mm-hm and his
great work that he spent his whole life
writing in search of lost time this is
about
time and it's about memory and it's
about how narrative reconstructs reality
twists it around and he and he creates a
theory of memory that has has tremendous
psychological validity and psychologists
today who think about voluntary versus
involuntary memory really are whether
they know it or not in debt to Proust
and soon after Proust there was James
Joyce's with Virginia Woolf and and they
were focusing on time in completely new
ways again and twisting it talk about
memory and time and and what what that
dance is well when you think about it
what is memory we we mind trouble we
might have a naive view because we're so
familiar with computers these days yeah
but I think this view may have even
predated computers that memory is a kind
of storage you know something that you
get the sensory input you put it in
there then you need it and you recall it
but that's not how our minds work and
psychologists know that now and Proust
knew it very well and philosophers have
known it too how do they work well I
shouldn't I shouldn't pretend that I'm
about to explain the secret of memory
but but one thing that I think is clear
is that it's an active process right we
know that we cannot simply call up at
will any memory that's in there and we
also know that memories come to us
involuntarily with Proust when he ate
that little cookie the middle oh right
we also know where we should know if if
we think about it that memory is an
active process every time we remember
something we are recreating it we are
telling a story again and when we
remember it the next time it might be a
little bit different and we all know
that it's possible at least I think we
should know that it's possible to have
vivid memories that turn out to be false
mm-hmm why because our minds are just
what they are and we don't have perfect
control over them because we are
our minds and you're suggesting that
we're traveling through time and this or
that we're creating our sense of time
with the narrative of our memories you
love Voorhis you quote him here jorge
luis borges
here's 1946 and i love this quote he
says time is a river that sweeps me
along but i am the river it is a tiger
that mangles me but I am the tiger it is
a fire that consumes me but I am the
fire is that him talking about our
narrative manipulation of I think it is
yes he thought a lot about time and as
you can see he loved to speak in riddles
and paradoxes which I believe as a
person who loves fiction can be a very
effective way of getting at reality it's
a way that competes with the way
physicists get at reality but physicists
don't have any better luck when trying
to say what time is so yes time is a
river time is a tiger time is a fire
that consumes us we use these metaphors
all the time and we know that there but
we also he say
I'm also the river that's right I am
also the tiger and he was in in a lot of
his writing he was he was very concerned
with this problem of perception and
consciousness and memory and you can ask
yourself how do I know what's my sense
of what is what is creating my sense of
the difference between the past and the
future why can't I as people say
remember the future why why do I have
such a strong sensation that it's now
and what's now is real and now I just
said that but that now a few seconds ago
is it's gone it's floating off somewhere
but where is it a physicist might like
to say it's just somewhere else in the
great four-dimensional space-time
continuum and that my sense that it's
gone is an illusion a lot of physicists
like to talk that way and my sense that
the past is not accessible because it's
open it hasn't happened yet that might
also be an illusion according to
physicists but not according to not
according to science fiction writers not
tube or haze we'll go deeper with them I
mean the great literary Minds struggle
with it you quote in a buck off saying
why is it so difficult so degrading ly
difficult to bring the notion of time
into mental focus and keep it there for
inspection what an effort what fumbling
what irritating fatigue is he talking
about the difficulty of defining what is
the present or this whole project of the
texture of time and why it's so hard to
grasp I think both I think he's there
he's talking about why don't here's the
thing that we're very familiar with why
don't we understand it why when we focus
on it doesn't it come into focus that's
what he said and he's he's in a way
echoing Augustine in the fourth century
the fifth century who has been quoted
many times consciously and unconsciously
in the century since Augustine said what
then is time if no one asks me I know
perfectly well but as soon as someone
makes me explain it I don't know and we
all we all feel that way I think and I
think it's that's more than just a equip
you know I think there's something
profound there he's not just saying it's
an illusion to think we know what time
is because when I try to explain it I
discovered that I don't know what it is
he's saying the other thing too he's
saying even though I can't explain it I
do have a lot of knowledge about time
and I think it's important for us to
recognize that and that's it's that's
kind of where I go in the book where I
finally break down and start to talk
about what time actually is yes that's
the case I'm trying to make that even
though it it's impossible for any of us
to say definitively we actually know a
great deal you say we've achieved a
temporal sentience that our ancestors
lacked what is that what's the what is
the shape of that sentience
well the fake of it is again not that
firm it's not firm and it's and it's
complicated because our sense of time
has built up from all these different
things we learn some things from
physicists whether we are
science students are not though they
despair you host Stephen Hawking saying
that he hosted a party for Time
Traveller's and you caught him saying i
sat there a long time but no one came
right that's true he announced he had an
invitation he said party for Time
Traveller's but the date was in the past
I didn't notice I couldn't see because
of the lights how many people said said
they were from the future
anybody have in the future right okay
nobody's even willing to nobody's even
willing to lie but so Hawking actually
Hawking loves to time to talk about time
travel because it's Fung and he doesn't
really think that time travel is
possible and one of his proofs I'm doing
air quotes now that there's no such
thing as time travel is if there were
such a thing as time travel we would
have time travelers from the future in
our midst and I I met a guy when I was
working on the book I said first night
first I met a woman at a cocktail party
and I said I was working on a book about
time travel and she said oh you have to
meet my boyfriend he's got a whole
theory and so he came over and he said
well you know how Hawking says their
time travel doesn't exist because there
are no time travelers from the future
well I know why that is it's because
they're afraid of disease and so what I
think we need to do is that disease for
them okay well you know the way
explorers go to a new continent and they
can't be smart to come back here I mean
you would think that they would have
good medical care in the future but
there must be romantics in the future I
mean I want to go back to King Arthur's
Court and I'd probably get the plague or
something but I'd still go right yeah
and by the way would you like to go back
or would you like to go forward can I do
both no I just want to get out of here
that same thing my aunt I was obsessed
with you know these uh medieval fairs
and she believed that she was the the
present-day reincarnation or constants
for manifestation of a 16th century
Belgian bar like a tavern wish
and she had a heck of a lot of fun at
these fairs but is that time travel yes
it is I mean for me of course nice now I
see time travel everywhere but yes we
have all this cosplay we we are able to
imagine ourselves into the past and we
are able to imagine ourselves into the
future in ways that just seem natural
but people a hundred years ago didn't do
quite so dexterously let's say our eyes
have been opened and so sure we tell
these stories we know what happens when
we meet ourselves in the past right we
are we argue about it we've gotten
pretty adept talk about the science
fiction writers you say that they've
achieved that they're often the ones who
give us the most rigorously analyzed
approaches time
I mean you know and we know you got in
the movies we got back to the future and
all that but talk about Kingsley Amos
the alteration of philip k dick the man
in the high castle what they were
putting forward oh those are good there
are two wonderful books that I'm sure
you could get somewhere around here and
they're both examples of of what we now
call alternative history where you you
reimagine the past what might have been
another great example is Philip Roth's
novel the plot against America
a few years ago where he he imagined
what America would be like if if the
fascists had won in that's 90 in 1940 no
I won't go there just out of here it's
valuable for us to do alternative
history it's a great mental exercise and
and it can be done more or less
rigorously you know you can really if
you're a historian I know historians who
really enjoy this exercise of trying to
work out you know what would have
happened if and that has some use but
and it's a new it's a new genre of it's
a kind of science fiction I mean it was
philip k dick imagining what if the
Japanese and Germans had won the war and
divided up the US and Kingsley Amis
imagining what if the Reformation had
never happened which might be a little
obscure for us but he works it all out
is that an examination of time of time
travel or is that just a if you arrange
dominoes in a different formation they
fall in a different direction it's a
it's another it's an I think it's an
example of our our mental dexterity our
ability to do that our ability to place
ourselves easily in the past and in
alternative pasts I'm there's another
fantastic book by Kate Atkinson two
books one after the other that I
imagined she's not quite a time traveler
her hero whose name is Ursula Todd
but she lives again and again sometimes
trying to kill Hitler by Groundhog Day
are different Groundhog Day is another
beautiful example of what I would call a
time travel movie right he's not really
traveling through time he's more stuck
in time the weather man who can never
get a weather man who has to live the
same day over and over again until he
gets it right the DeLorean and Back to
the Future that was huge
you couldn't have done it in 1894 before
the time machine right what about their
perception the way the way that movie
played
Marty and Doc and all the rest yeah the
movie is fun and it's sort of the
DeLorean is another great device to head
to the list of time machines I mean
there are elevators there are doors
there windows
sure there holes in the air but
there's something serious to say about
that story and I think really about
every time travel story when you think
about them and that is and what's what's
going on in that story emotionally when
you think about it here's a teenager and
he reaches a certain age and he looks at
his parents and a light bulb illuminates
and he thinks oh they were teenagers
once did they feel did my dad feel about
girls the way I feel could I find out
and he the fantasy takes off from there
and it's and when you think about it a
lot of time-travel stories involve
parents or children meeting children in
the future meeting parents and doors
yes seeing them one more time changing
in that case the way the course of
things you quote Ursula Gwyn saying
story is our only boat for sailing on
the river of time and now we seem to be
in the heart of your sympathies here
this is really a realm of story as much
as physics or anything else yeah what's
she telling us well Ursula K Le Guin is
another a magnificent writer could have
won the Nobel Prize this year although I
doubt there are too many people in here
who were unhappy about the choice of
Nobel Prize for Literature like a
rolling stone yeah okay don't start no
she's a science fiction writer and there
are a lot of science fiction writers who
interestingly seldom venture into
time-travel she wrote many stories set
in the future but tried to avoid literal
time travel but wrote a wonderful book
the lathe of heaven that involves a
dreamer it's this is kind of alternative
history again only it's not the past
that's changing it's the future that's
changing whenever he dreams he wakes up
and the world is now a little bit
different or a lot different because of
what he dreamed and the horror for him
is that he's the only person who's aware
of this and he can't control his dreams
so sometimes terrible things happen
is that time-travel kind of technology
continues to change our relationship
with the present the past is more and
more easy to capture and carry forward
with us maybe the algorithms out there
are predicting for us what we're going
to do next maybe bringing us the future
how do you see technology now I mean HG
Wells had is sort of fancy bicycle with
ivory and leather and steampunky kind of
time machine or what about all the
gizmos we have now and how they were
changing our relationship with time
that's that's a really good question and
it's something I think about a lot and
and I think it's something we all are
need to keep an eye on and our learning
learning about us we live through it you
know we we live in this instantaneous
networked world information comes to us
at Lightspeed
from all around the globe it comes to us
on screens big screens and little
screens and sometimes several screens
simultaneously and we're getting
messages sometimes from the same person
in different channels and then you have
to figure out did this text message
saying I'm right around the corner come
first or did this email saying no I'm
gonna meet you at the movie theater come
first and then you have to look at the
timestamps and then the past is mixed up
with the future meanwhile we have
tremendous access to the past we know
more about the lives of Bach and
Beethoven and Mozart and Mahler and
Stravinsky than they knew than any of
them knew about their predecessors we
have instant access to all of their
music the music from our personal pasts
the music that we loved when we were
kids remain is this available to us as
as music from ancient times and from
music that's just being recorded
yesterday and it all gets mixed up
together so we're in a kind of eternal
present that you you say that there's a
philosophy in our society that we should
live in the
that's exactly where we should be but
that that doesn't really make sense to
you
now I've developed doubts about that be
here now yeah be here now it's been a
lot of time trying to do that live in
the now
we're told don't waste brain cells
agonizing over what might have been or
what's coming don't waste brain cells
wishing for something you can never have
or fearing a future that might happen
live in the now immerse yourself in in
sensation I've decided that that's
that's not how I want to live that's not
that's how plants live plants live in
the now what how do you know that I'm
pretty sure okay
what what makes us human is that we know
a lot about the past now we are able to
imagine the future keep using these same
hands we think the future might be there
or there or there any way we can imagine
it and we can mix memory with
anticipation and still enjoy the present
and I think that's good we're gonna take
your questions in just a few minutes
here there's a microphone right here if
you've got a question for James Glick on
time time travel bring it right on up do
you fantasize about it do you ever do
you have a wish list of if you could
have three three time trips where you'd
take off for I've always I always
thought I wanted to go to the future
and and then was a little surprised when
it turns out that so many people just
have no interest in that and would
rather go to the past I mean I can
imagine going to the past and meeting
Isaac Newton and you know I have some
questions for him but I really would
like to see you want to be there at the
moment when he put the knife into his
eye that wouldn't necessarily be my
favorite moment why did he do that again
it were now we're digressing okay but
yes we're talking about that before it's
it's true that Isaac Newton believer in
experimentation wanting to figure out
whether light was different from
pressure or the same as pressure
actually poked a bodkin as he called it
Shakespearean Lee
it into his eye and then late drunks and
wrote down the funny stuff that he saw
anyway I want equivalent experience
about Tom experiment about time what
would you do
I don't know throw a knife forward and
try and beat it I don't know we don't
want anybody here going home and
starting to play with all I know I let
me answer your question I want it I do
want to go to the future I don't know
when I'm not as thrilled about it as I
was a few years ago because the
futurists in so many ways starting to
look a little bleak but I really do
wonder what is can you know our I want
to go to wherever it is that we turn
into the the proverbial hive mind the
world brain you want that you're ready
for the borer the Borg collective I'm
not saying I want I mean you're right
you want to see it what I want to see
what that's like then what what
interests you about it they'll just plug
you in and make you a cipher I'm that's
exactly what I'm curious about
I'm wondering whether that's a good
thing or a bad thing I'm wondering
whether because I do think it's it's
happening now we are partly made of
silicon most almost everybody in this
room has a device in his or her pocket
by which they access all the world's
knowledge and and in a few years it's
going to be contact lens or implants I
hope I'm not bringing bad news here but
I'm genuinely curious about is the
extent to which we will be able to
retain our individuality and yet these
stories of travel I mean it's
appropriate write a book festival what's
more effective than a book at the kind
of time travel that you're including in
time travel that is are letting our
minds roll yeah well I think it's fair
to say that that the best time machines
we have our books you say we need these
stories for history for mystery for
nostalgia for hope still hopeful from
time travel let's say yes let's we'll
say yes look there are people lined up
awesome let's take your questions yes
please
I wonder how much time related
management techniques are synchronized
with this fictional investigation of
time travel because I think of you know
looking back at some of the management
techniques that are you know a little
over a hundred years old but I also look
at the now where we're using data and
analytics to understand the past and use
that to understand you mean like for an
assembly line or something Henry Ford of
the stopwatch exactly yes and I just
sort of see the fiction of time travel
sort of going along with the use of that
in the industrial world yeah that's
that's an interesting question it's not
something I go into in this book but it
it is true that a hundred years ago a
little more than a hundred years ago not
at the beginning of the Industrial
Revolution but closer to our time people
started to get very obsessed with
measuring time very precisely in
factories and making their workers more
efficient and that is a nightmare may I
say that continues to this day because
we're we're all too good at clocking one
another and now we have all of this
machine power dedicated to the what-ifs
and the what's coming next
yeah you still we start saying here time
is a measured portion of eternity and
pretty soon you've got a clock on your
work on the assembly line yes please
thank you very much
so I wonder if you could address the
idea of ideas and creativity as a time
travel I mean the the idea that that
that spark in one's imagination that can
help to create new technologies new new
ways of doing things is that time travel
when you create something that's going
to be used in the future I I wouldn't go
so far as to say that I think that every
spark of creativity is a form of time
travel I certainly am saying it the
other way around that too to think about
time
to imagine the past to imagine the
future we need to be creative it's a
that's a creative act either way
and what about premonitions do they fit
in well premonitions are another another
kind of time-travel fantasy and and
there are people who there are people
who started writing books about time in
the early part of the 20th century that
were based on their experience of waking
up after a dream and discovering then or
sometime later that their dream was
actually true and thinking oh I have had
access to the future which of course I
don't believe actually happens I think
it does okay well thank you how many
people do you do merit imagination as a
kind of and we imagine the past we
imagine the future I don't know maybe I
don't know how close premonition and
imagination lied to one another yes sir
I've heard that story told that when the
modern day keyboard was invented it was
designed to actually slow down typers
because it would get stuck the old
mechanical typewriter so today we're
still stuck with that keyboard even
though there might be a little more
alternatives for tuition right so when
we think about time and we go through
the time during the course of a day for
whatever reason we've divided it into
twenty four parts per day and so as
you've thought about time I'm wondering
is there a more effective way to divide
up the day instead of just 24 parts
would it be ten or a hundred or did you
think at all about that
well I meaning of it out was I am loath
to give advice to give personal advice
to anybody but I would say the most
effective and creative thing to do would
be not to start dividing the day into
regular parts but to let our obsession
with time slip away
why what is the advantage in that
because we need a little we need a
little of everything we need some
balance we don't always need to be
multitasking and we're
at high speed we don't always need to be
acutely aware of the passing seconds
sometimes we need to let our minds drift
I mean that's what we do when we read a
book yeah I mean does that change
reality you go all the way back to 1814
where they talked about what they called
the universe rigid the effect of its
past and the cause of its future and as
if all these things in sequence
necessitated the next and everything was
an illogical kind of firm chain
unbreakable yeah and there are still
physicists who like to think that way as
though everything is determined by the
laws of physics I think we know better
you write the universe rigid is a prison
only the time travel can call himself
free sir thank you I don't know if you
mentioned in the book but my favorite
time travel story is a sound of thunder
by Ray Bradbury and I wonder if you
could comment on it especially because
it rubs up against chaos theory which
you've also we tell us the central
premise for those like me who haven't
read that what have you sure I can tell
you oh good yeah no I mean my basic
nightmare by the way is that people are
going to ask are going to mention their
favorite time travel story or movie or
TV show and the odds are that it's not
described in my book but in this case
bingo jackpot the sound of thunder by
Ray Bradbury is a is a terrific story
I'm sure a lot of people here know it it
involves it involves a sort of
time-traveling safari operation safari
Safari Safari Safari where for money
big-game hunters who are tired of
elephants and lions can go back into the
past and shoot dinosaurs you know I I
imagined that I imagined these as the
erich Trump's of of their time
awesome and not to not to spoil the
story totally the twist is that somebody
steps on a butterfly goes off the path
and just stepping on this butterfly
changes the course of history so that
some terrible stuff happens in the
present and this is before this right
this Ray Bradbury story is before chaos
theorists invented the notion of the
butterfly effect which is based on the
same premise but it also raises yet
another of these issues that come up
when you're doing time-travel stories
that the science fiction writers were
the first ones to have to deal with
logically you ask yourself if you go
into the past first of all would you be
able to interact with it or would you
just be a sort of free-floating
consciousness and then if you can
interact with it
can you change things and then if you do
change things and this is a more
sophisticated question but it's one that
the science fiction writers got to for
first if you bump you know if there are
perturbations in history would history
tend to get back on to its natural track
or would it get into wild divergences so
that stepping on the butterfly would
mess everything up don't expect me to
give you the answer okay okay we're on
the edge of our seat now you you can
take your pick that's the point the
science fiction writers you know you can
pick Isaac Asimov's the end of eternity
which very clearly expresses the former
view that yes you can mess things up but
mostly history tries to write itself and
get get back onto a path or maybe we all
have our own version to quote Charles
lamb back in 1817 your now is not mine
now and again your then is not mine in
then but mine now maybe your then in
vice-versa
whose head is competent to these things
of yours I'm really glad you mentioned
Eric Trump because as we've been talking
oh I meant not to not do that I'm sorry
as we keep talking I keep thinking about
this desire that people seem to have
certain
element of the country seems to have for
a return to the past this kind of make
America great again
the idea that maybe the Trump train is a
vehicle for try and travel these climate
political realm have you thought it all
about sort of the notion how politics is
affected by the ideas of time travel in
our culture touch on that honestly
there's there's I don't think there's
any politics in my book I do I do think
about nostalgia and you can think about
nostalgia without having to discuss its
political consequences you know no
nostalgia is another kind of mental time
travel it's another it's another way in
which we imagine the past and and
sometimes our imagination misleads us
we're we're overly creative and
nostalgia works both ways you know you
can remember the past and make it out to
be rosy colored or you can imagine the
past and make it out to be more dire
than it was and it could be a matter of
personality do you feel it's happening
now no I'm not going to I've said enough
about the current election so from their
earliest recording evidence of humans we
there's you know issues of spirituality
and religion that are recorded and it
seems like it's something that humans
have always needed to do to sort of make
sense of their present in terms of a
larger picture and maybe explain their
current problems and concerns in terms
of relief you know from this larger
system and as during the course the
conversation this afternoon it struck me
that time travel sounds like a rational
mechanized response to this ancient
human need I mean in a way you can
modify or get away from your current
needs by going to the future of going to
the past making changes or just getting
away from what you're in the middle of
right now in your research and writing
did you rub up against ideas like that
at all is that
something that it what I always what I
would say is many religions maybe every
religion when they construct a spiritual
view of time when they try to think
about time it's it's common in religion
to think about being outside of time
eternity whatever it means to you is not
just a length of time and infinitude
it's also a way of being outside of time
when the ancient Egyptians when the
fairies pharaohs excuse me buried
themselves in order to preserve their
bodies they weren't so much thinking
about the future I mean they certainly
weren't thinking about being dug up by
people in the in the 19th and 20th
centuries they were thinking about
another world that was outside of time
and I think a lot of religions when they
imagined something like heaven are again
thinking about timelessness so maybe
this is the the thrust of your question
both spirituality and time travel are a
way of escaping from something that
otherwise is has us in its grasp I mean
you say that anyone who thinks about
time travel is ultimately thinking about
death escaping death I do I did
eventually arrive at that unhappy
conclusion in a way that that that's
what that's what time is most important
good Thalia like a do you yeah well I
mean it's fun to go back in the DeLorean
but really I do feel that lurking in the
background of every time travel story
and sometimes in the foreground is is a
desire for immortality because what does
time do time buries us yes sir thank you
and I'm look forward to reading the book
even if the answer is no to my question
index yet but dude talking about or
delve into
George Kubler he wrote a book called the
shape of time for kind of alternative
trajectories to think through art
history and visual visual art and
production like that now you've run it
out what's his idea he's a kind of a
pre-columbian artist or expert and he's
thinking through you know alternatives
to the Western Canon and and different
ways of looking through art history that
aren't about iconography but actually I
really think about form and he starts
off by talking about how all tools are
works of art and kind of tries to adjust
you know what's on the higher what it's
what if the hierarchy is of artistry as
well as the record of human production I
love it again alternate ways of looking
at the time or history so in a yell
university art historian 1968 Kubler
Kubler good uvl yeah okay thank you very
much yes and another are you from the
past future or present all right then
anyways so I'm a junior in high school
and we were having a conversation in
English class about how authors use
their writing from the past to
communicate with people from the future
or to continue to live on through their
writing so I was wondering if you
touched upon anything like that in your
book I think that's a really good
question
I think people who write books people
who do any kind of creative art that is
meant to last must be thinking in some
way about the future about posterity
when you write something down it's a way
of sending a message to the future
people might not have expressed it that
way hundreds of years ago it might be
that you're more immediate impulse is to
send a message to people in the present
you know but we do think about posterity
and the question of sending messages to
the future is something that we are
sometimes
or conscious of and sometimes less
conscious of you know so another thing I
write about at some length in the book
is is the phenomenon of people burying
time capsules which became very popular
about fifty years ago maybe a little
more and and there's a way of sending a
message to the future and saying here's
what we were like here's what our
culture was like I'm gonna assemble a
bunch of objects and books and magazines
and artifacts and bury them in a capsule
so that somebody who's curious a hundred
years from now will will dig them up and
say aha your junior in high school we
love that you brought your question
thank you there's a I wonder if there's
a different perception of time by age
you quote John Banville here saying
being young I was skeptical of the
future and saw it as a matter of
potential only a state of things that
might or might not arise and probably
never would have you found yourself were
observed others more or less interested
in time time travel texture of time with
with a different portion or stage of
life maybe the young just don't need to
care no I I think I think certainly the
interest in time travel starts earlier
and earlier I don't I don't have any
sense that either the young or the old
young Burt G was into it are more
obsessed with time sir
so Planet of the Apes yeah shoot out
come back approaching the speed light
sort of sounds like the Einstein's way
of explaining it right and where we
spend I don't know how many millions of
dollars sending out frequencies of the I
think at the frequency of hydrogen with
messages that were sending out to the
universe which they may be receiving ten
thousand years from now right are we not
looking at the past in the future at the
same time we're looking at the past yes
when we look at stars we are looking at
the past of those stars and and that's
an idea that people recognized even
before Einstein as soon as you know
I hope I don't mess up the history too
much here but it was it was in the
middle of the 19th century that people
established not only that light has
affixed has a finite speed but exactly
what that speed was Maxwell did that in
establishing electromagnetism here he
actually determined the speed of light
and so immediately a few smart people
recognized that that meant that light
that was coming to us from very far away
in distance was also coming to us from
very far away in time and that's why we
measure distance in terms of light years
I don't think we can see into the future
yes just a couple more hi so in the
beginning of your talk you started out
mentioning HD Wells 1895 and how he was
a futurist thinking about future times
I'm wondering about Darwin and how by
that point evolution you know what was
more or less in the popular
consciousness yes and also there were a
lot of explorers digging up bones in
other countries and you know the age of
exploration was big and so thinking
about the past was definitely kind of a
newer vivid newer thing and pretty vivid
in the popular imagination so I wonder
if you touch on that as well and whether
kind of the you know the urge to think
about how do humans fit in the past
maybe it was that part of what
influenced HG Wells as well as thinking
about the future
absolutely that's exactly right and I've
hardly I've really only given a sketchy
view of the things that that made it
possible finally in 1895 for HG Wells to
invent this wacky idea you're you're
right the Darwin was part of it and HG
Wells as a student studied Darwin and
also Lyell who was creating a new sense
of geology that involved visualizing
ancient ages of the past buried in rock
strata and as you suggested archeology
was also a new thing people were digging
up ancient civilizations and really for
the arts our sense of how old the earth
was had changed dramatically that it was
no longer six thousand years old
forgive me but I want to end with the
reading from this wonderful book would
you be kind of just read this paragraph
for us next to the last there okay
live in the now certain sages advise
they mean focus immerse yourself in your
sensory experience bask in the incoming
sunshine without the shadows of regret
or expectation but why should we kos
away our hard-won insight into times
possibilities and paradoxes we lose
ourselves that way what more terrifying
revelation can there be than that it is
the present moment wrote Virginia Woolf
that we survived the shock at all is
only possible because the past shelters
us on one side the future on another our
entry into the past and the future
fitful and fleeting though it may be
makes us human James click time travel a
history thank you very much well
wonderful to have you here wonderful to
have you here the book will be available
with Jim a James click at the back of
the hall thank you very much for being
here today thank you for coming thank
you so much enjoy the rest of the
festival